tell me I said it's the last time I had
sex was about what seven weeks ago oh my
word what about you today has any other
women had sex I said several weeks ago
weeks
trust me it's not it's not it's not that
is by a choice What It Is by choice so I
didn't mean it went by choice but it's
not like I'm happy about it but it's
like a you gotta think bigger than the
temptation of the day I'm not gonna lie
I'll be so honest with you yeah I'll be
honest I'm saying this out of respect I
don't care you don't believe me you
[ __ ] yesterday
honestly I didn't yes
but it's like in my mind I'm thinking
about the bigger picture that's that's a
bit of self-consciousness
okay so for me I feel like the bigger
picture is if I don't open up my legs I
feel like it's a better Gateway for a
guy to take me serious more so I feel
like
I don't wanna the reason why I'm not
having sex right now is because I feel
like the next guy I wanna I don't want
to have sex with a guy and it just be
that see you in a wedding period where
you're you're trying to identify that
guy to open sesame's for no no I just
feel like for me I want to if I want it
to be more deeper I want it to go down
the relationship bro you haven't got
someone that you think cool I don't want
a relationship
I had that I did have that you wanted
more for yourself and then I was like
now I want my experience
let's ask the guys girls what what
should girls do
how long should how long would you wait
for a girl before you're you're saying
no Seven Days
Seven Days
seven days what about you I can only
speak from us personally every girl I've
had sex with I've never waited more than
five or six days anyway hey you see a
big dog you know
I don't know any difference so it's hard
to answer that question okay how long
would you wait
only the five was like between five and
six days because that's all I've ever
done come see this horny [ __ ]
whatever what if she was she seemed
wifey how long would you give her even
that's what I'm saying that's got a week
do you want to be married at some point
[Laughter]
possibly possible
how long would you wait if I'm looking
at her like worthy potential yeah I want
her to at least wait two weeks two weeks
okay and then how long how long is too
long
a month
okay now seriously I'm sticking to my
seven days
seven days are balanced okay see I'll be
honest yeah
see me I'll I'm willing like it's a bit
of a I'm willing to wait longer for you
to respect your thing if I feel like
it's genuine that you're trying to
figure me out if I'm you're trying to
actually see it assess me as a is he
like a proper guy or whatnot if I feel
like you're just
you're like you're not actually trying
to figure me out you're just trying to
prove a point to yourself that you can
wait there's the Egypt you're not gonna
hear from you again but in general it
doesn't matter what like no matter what
the man them say like they've said two
weeks seven days what not really and
truly like I could wait for you I could
wait two months because I feel like
whatever whatever but try not demand
them are beating there's Nets get a lot
of free now
so it's just where you can do that
approach but you have to also know the
consequences more than likely demanding
my beat like you you're he's been
reviewing that he ain't got no I might
have got two kids and rub up and that's
it and then what is at the door all
right cool when Shelly Ann's down the
road
okay Auntie what are you saying from
your perspective how long should women
wait if they're not I just want to ask
another way let me change it for you I
you ask the man I want to ask the ladies
is that right can I do that yeah go
ahead I want to ask the ladies for my
time what's the longest time you spent
from seeing a guy you liked to sleeping
with the guy and was he the one what's
the longest I'm here seven days I want
to hear from the women what's the
longest you went from meeting a guy he
said I like him to actually sleeping
with him what's the longest Gap
start anyway
for me the longest ever would be um my
my ex partner my baby dad that I was
with for eight years because we lost our
journey to each other so obviously yeah
there was over a year oh yeah from the
time you saw it imagine two so when I
lost my virginity to him he lost his so
what about after the time you saw him
that's the longest Gap you've ever had
no not from the time I saw him because
we established we liked each other after
we met each other but from the time that
we realized that we that we were not
that we we're for each other yeah there
was no pressure on sex because he never
so because he never had sex Neva so he
didn't put pressure on me because he was
both virgins so it that time was right
for us so was he the one no he wasn't
okay
so and the next lady please the next
lady so I
um waited three months for a guy I
really liked because I thought the whole
mind the whole theory of you know keep
it close you know I mean anyway I got
played and I took a l because that's
what I said yeah I mean I did take it
out with that one simply because it was
when it was taking it ill yeah I took a
lot of space okay he played me basically
and I was like played yourself no I
didn't
oh okay okay all right I'll be fair then
but no yeah I don't feel like I played
myself I just feel because I do because
you like to I do feel like the the
majority not every guy but I do feel
like the majority of guys have the same
mindset of you as if you [ __ ] too quick
so let me say something so let me say
something you waited three months yeah
you made the guy you like wait three
months so you see in previously
previously here I bet there's guys that
you ain't even like that much that you
probably beat within weeks like a week
because you don't like them like that no
but obviously for you look I hear what
you are saying but you see for men you
know what bro for men yeah you know what
I'm saying
if a guy if a guy takes you on a first
date and it's it's the nicest first date
you've ever been on like you you can all
think of one where he just went above
and beyond for you and you knew he liked
you a lot and and to guys it's like the
quicker you sleep with them it's the
more you like them really yeah what do
they say those things though when like
like I'm not saying all guys again but
why do they say that oh man [ __ ] on
the first night she's a jazz or like
they'd be like yeah yeah because because
this is and this is this is why it's
like a double-edged sword because they
they want they want you to be a hoe just
for them yeah
it's kind of like it's kind of like you
want a guy that treats you better than
he treated all these others like you
know what like if
the same way
it's like she said no to all of them but
she let me hit it but it's like it's a
different thing than when yeah
it's put them off before like they think
because because he thinks that's
something immature men it's because it's
because she won't be dead it's because
he thinks you're doing it with everyone
and so that's why I said it's there's no
winning uh there's no secret I think if
there is a secret formula on how how to
get what you want out of a relationship
like everyone would buy it there's no
winning secret but I'm saying like that
the reason that it puts them off is
because they think you're doing it with
everyone and women lie so much like how
the hell are they supposed to know
if if when I when I was dating if I met
a girl and she put out on the first date
I'm thinking she's doing that to every
single man she's going on a date with
you know what I mean so and then I'm not
going to believe anything she says if a
girl puts out on her first date and says
her body counts five I'm like you're
late what if she put out and then you
heard from your friend that he she
turned him down would that change it or
no I'm just curious no because she
probably turned she could have just said
yes to Bear oven
okay fair enough go ahead
and it was mum's when she first met I'm
not gonna ask this young lady I don't
want to ask because I don't want to know
I don't want to know this is not for you
I'm not asking you nothing so just
listen right I don't want to hear
so what it is no I was the same question
that I was saying but now now you said
you met him when you was a virgin you
said you put out after how many years
nobody's sure about the one
I met my partner
and we were friends hanging out with
each other with a group of friends
for over two years well I got to know
him before
no you didn't see me like that we were
friends no he was a friend he was
friends though and that's different I
liked him he liked me I was hanging out
with another guy so we became friends
and then when we hit it off and we
started sleeping together nobody else
got in between how long did it take
though
young ladies right is that when they
hang out with women they don't find that
[ __ ] from women you understand I hang
out with men so and then their men work
so I didn't care who he been over
because it wasn't me I see you know I've
been best friends with men and seen them
got with girls and sleep with girls and
I'm like watch out for that girl you
know I mean because I'm like the friend
the proper with the guys so when you get
to when you got to know me and realized
that you know what she's all right then
when it comes to having sex I know what
men are like you're asking me I'm gonna
say yes because you know that if you've
got a woman that got of a group of
friends a group of male friends nobody's
gonna approach you but there's one guy
that would approach it and say you know
what and I liked him so I said well why
not he goes well ain't gonna I'm gonna
say no come on it's been two years I've
been watching you are you watching am I
gonna say no so you said Auntie but the
difference like it's a generational
thing right because because no because
because this is the generational thing
like before if if a guy if a girl was
turning guys down on the first date and
making him wait guys knew that like she
wasn't sleeping around because she
usually wasn't but the problem is now
guys are putting in all this effort and
waiting for a girl and they find out
she's screwed everyone else before and
so but in your days like women I would
assume women weren't as like sleeping
around right but like he said if I if I
knew that I wasn't going to sleep with
him he's gonna go and sleep with other
people I don't mind because it's not me
I'm aware of it how you said you know he
might take me out on a date drop me off
to my doorstep I'm gonna screw someone I
don't care about that because I know
that you dropped me home we had a nice
time go and get your rock
[Music]
as many of you know I was just banned on
Tick Tock and we are demonetized on a
daily basis on this platform if you want
to help please consider are sending a
super thanks below every donation helps
and it helps make what we do possible